[Music]
Our battle begins after everything is over It's
not like anyone will be paying attention to us, but it's our
battle against a monster that the sun never shines on. This
is what we're aiming for, come on!  Dreams are the
captain's feet, and I'll be defending myself. Let's
annihilate all the monsters together. If it's just the two of us, then it's
not scary. After all,
we should be defensemen. Let's go. Hey, I'm one more defenseman.
Eyes,
senpai. Eh, I'm going to
run away.  Yo, senpai, what's with the collection?
[ __ ], I have to go next to that guy who never gives up. I'll
follow you. Well
then, let's get started, Mikiko Kashi. My hobby is killing monsters. There's no
guarantee of life. I'm going to
kill you.  We will subjugate it and never give up. We will kill it. We will
never give up.
Monster No. 8. This individual is the eighth monster that the defense forces have given a code name to.